pratique elle en a peaufiné avec moi
aujourd'hui elle a reçu des ordres
répondra pas aux téléphones de journée à
mettre un peu le met dehors je veux pas
que par la personne robert lalonde
on vous a vu à la télévision vous avez
joué en 50 ans de carrière dans 150
pièces de théâtre et vous avez publié 29
livres la première question vous accro
au travail
je suis accro à la création pas au
travail pour moi je dirais ça je pense
que quand on est créateur quand on
détruit même quand on est comédien et
tout ce qu'il faut c'est trouver une
façon de faire est là quelques jours je
peux attendre huit heures dans une
journée
donc ils sont fins trouve un bureau ils
savent que j'ai utilisé mes tantes
islande puis vient le chercher car ces
motos et c'est mon tempérament un mois
j'ai découvert que j'ai tué beaucoup
mieux quand j'étais pas en position
d'écriture quand j'appelle en l'air un
peu projet pas d'affaires à écrire
l'appui c'est pas le moment où là il
vient beaucoup de choses le départ de
mes livres se sont pas fait assez à mon
bureau
ça s'est fait en déplacement en bougeant
dans la vie les choses qui sont arrivées
donc j'essaie de prendre tous ces
moments là pour travailler
je ne sais pas si c'est d'acharnement et
ou si c'est pas plus que le désir
fondamental que j'ai de fuir les
situations place malgré la taz il ya peu
sociable vous aimez plus ou moins
socialiser inutilement le second temps
puis moi on est vraiment parfait on
s'entend
j'essaie d'éviter gemain beaucoup les
gens qui on m'écoute et dire ce ventre
c'est terry pour pouvoir aller
travailler
je m'ennuie je m'ennuie ces
conversations là parce qu'on a eu c'est
dix fois puis parce que ça c'est
terrible pour moi et puis qui me vient
une idée que je me dis si je reste le
lob que j'attendais dans mon bureau je
vais la période
je dis que j'ai rendez vous important
sera fait je le mets dans un coin du
travail ce qui est mis à mal juste
profane que j'ai mon pouce man le film
est votre livre c'est le coeur qui
marrant derniers ont vraiment connu un
succès d'estimé vraiment important
populaire rousselet comment vous
expliquer avec leur recul que cette
histoire ait touché autant de gens c'est
le récit de deux à votre mère justement
et de vous tourner la page en quelque
sorte si j'en étais toute ligne orange
est pas élevé donc pas mal de femmes qui
ressemble à ma main dans la vie de
plusieurs personnes et l'autre raison
c'est je pense c'est une question je
dirais de wii presque de techniques
narratives j'ai essayé d'écrire un livre
à vendre des années que je marchais pas
fait dans la doléance pilule quand j'ai
décidé de faire le portrait de ma mère
et de ma santé le plus possible - comme
narrateur de l'histoire
on l'a vu apparaître tout à coup ça ça
m'a plu c'est comme ça qu'il faut le
faire et depuis je souhaite les gens qui
mentent en disant c'est ma mère c'est ma
grand mère c'est donc ma mère que je
croyais unique au monde
apparemment ne l'était pas tous
j'ai beaucoup aimé votre dernier livre
fait hagard fais ta joie
il n'a failli jamais voir le jour ce
livre là parce que votre maison a brûlé
expliquez-moi comment vous l'avez
retrouvé dans un orateur qui était aussi
qu'elles signent très bien pendant que
ça brûlait parce que ça dure et l'est
toujours
le pompier a que je salue
fraternellement qui ont été formidables
dans cet accord là mais disent quelque
chose dans ma maison c'est là que je
peux aller chercher pendant mais la
flamme là partout soudain j'ai dit que
de mon ordinateur et sur mon bureau en
bas mais c'est en bas donc c'est aussi
précipité il va amener un paquet de
plastique est quelqu'un qui est un
spécialiste d'aller chercher des données
dans ça aidera à trouver le texte d'un
jeu commun de la fabrique d'une langue
basque s'y est pris même si
graphiquement agriculteurs parce qu'elle
dit a jamais eu copie choco psa mais
c'est vrai que c'est ma délinquance le
temps devient plus problématique
oui mais voilà c'est un survivant vous
êtes un grand lecteur et dans cet
incendie vous avez perdu vos 4000 livres
ça fait quoi de perdre tous ses livres
une partie de votre histoire vous savez
comminges affectionne le paradoxe
j'étais obligé divers d'avoir recours
encore ça fait des années avant l'
incendie que je faisais le tour n'a vu
le très grand et fort je me débats c'est
pourquoi je gagne je relirai pas ça
c'est oui c'est l'egypte et je me
mettais pas parce que je trouvais là
vous en faire déprimant puis finalement
je procrastine est serré c'est là le feu
à régler ça c'est parti
je sais pas chier avec l'âge une espèce
de désir de croire à l'idée qu'il faut
tourner les pages et madame et puis que
si c'est pas nous qui décidons si le
sort en décide pour nous il faut aborder
le port je voudrais pas qu'il ya des
journées où ça fait rare bon je sais
qu'ils jouent senard a tout brûlé
j'avais plein de notre là dedans et puis
fou je dis bon c'est passé c'est autre
chose que j'ai à faire maintenant voilà
trop vers l'avant
merci